welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down the Mandalorian season 3
episode 1 is now here and throughout
this video we're going to be going
through the brand new entry and all the
Star Wars Easter eggs in it this season
is building off the back of the book of
Baba fed and as I know a lot of you
missed it I want to give a quick recap
in case you're scratching your head over
why grocer mandoah back together now in
the final handful of episodes we watched
Mando fighting the armorer which is
where he practiced his skills with the
darksaber because he was at odds with
himself though he couldn't properly
yield it and he was told that he needed
to regain his honor after removing his
helmet thus he must return to the Living
Waters beneath Mandalore which will sort
of provide a baptism for the character
this left him as an apostate which means
someone who has a band in a religious or
political principle Mando's cult were
told not to remove their helmets no
matter what and on the opposite side of
this we've seen bulkdan's group are
happy to do this this could potentially
lead into a Civil War and judging by the
trailer that's the way things are going
to be going we've had things like the
Death Watch battling the pacifist
leaders of Mandalore and Civil Wars
throughout the Saga so it's definitely
on brand each side always tends to seek
the darksaber and I think that's gonna
become a big weapon in this season now
after gaining an N1 Starfighter Amanda
went to visit Luke and grogu in order to
find peace but after some advice from
Ahsoka he decided not to interfere with
the training however Ellie shot grokou
decided to go back to his dad and we
watched as a pair were reunited towards
the end of the season now that should be
a fully caught up and from here on out
it's full spoilers ahead so if you
haven't had a chance to check it out
then I highly recommend that you check
out now if you enjoy the video then you
will hit the Thumbs Up Button doing a
little Jedi mind trick there and make
sure you subscribe for videos like this
every day by the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
Mandalorian season three
now we begin with the armrest starting
up their smelting pot I think it's
called that and this Forge is something
that's of course popped up throughout
every season so far it's where Mando had
both his weapons and armor made and it
very much represents a place in which
transformation happens symbolically the
fires we see here could represent the
restoration of the mandalorians sparking
up again and we see these Flames shot so
that they're below the mythosaur symbol
that the mandalorians wear mythosaurs
were ancient beasts that were hunted by
the mandalorians and no extinct they
very much represent the challenges that
they used to face biting one is very
much seen as a rite of passage and we
see something similar here in this
introduction with a child being
presented with a helmet before a giant
Beast attacks I view this ointment being
poured into the bowl as the start of a
sort of baptism or christening and it's
similar how they are carried out rather
than dunking the child's head though the
helmet is dunked instead and this very
much becomes the face that the Amorous
Clan have so this being dip makes sense
as it's what the child will wear for the
rest of their life during the New
Republic era the armor was the leader of
the children of the watch and thus
there's this idea of kids laced
throughout their Clan outside we get
further religious imagery with a child
standing in a vast body of water and
this is similar to how a baptism is
carried out there's also of course a
saying a baptism of fire and thus we
have this represented in the flames and
also what comes next now this child is
potentially a family and ninjara may
have gone through a similar thing when
he was younger several of the
mandalorians have gathered here and this
is similar how communities come together
for religious ceremonies like this at
this point we see Paz Whistler as well
he's been a reoccurring character that's
popped up throughout the show and he's
voiced by none other than my man John
Fabro it is possible that favs might
actually end up cameo in the series as
well and there was a figure released
recently that showed Paz with his helmet
off carrying his likeness potentially we
might see something where his clan
agrees to finally remove their helmets
to unite Mandalore and he'll take us off
to reveal his face I think that would be
such a cool way to bring one of the guy
eyes behind it into the series and
fingers crossed that's what happens down
the line the helmets put on a bowl
stepped into the water and the kid
promises to never remove it again hope
their head doesn't grow but obviously
that they can remove it they just need
to do it in private like what we saw in
season one anyway the giant crocodile
attacks looking like it was ripped out
of like Placid and the Creed all mounted
up to take it on this is similar to a
mythical hunt and how the group would
all team up when all hope seems lost
everyone's getting knocked out the N1
Starfighter flies in and Mano enters the
scene by killing the creature with ease
now Mando's N1 Naboo Starfighter of
course pulls from The Phantom Menace and
this new repurposed one fits more of the
idea that the direction of this season
will be heading rise in the past Mando
was collecting bounties this clearly
doesn't have the space for many as it
just sits one person and and a little
kid on his knee I guess samando has now
moved away from that life and he's more
focused on restoring Mandalore to its
former glory you also know that the
Astro Droid he'll be getting will be
r5d5 4. this character actually popped
up in a new hope and he was the Droid
that got busted up and meant that R2D2
could go with Luke instead we've seen
this broken exhaust Port before and he's
of course been around Pele models hangar
in previous Seasons where you can even
see oil leaking out the back of that
port and there's actually a non-canon
comic that talks about R5 and that's
called Skippy the Jedi Droid which I
have to stop it basically talks about
how he's a force sensitive Droid that
actually broke himself so that R2D2
could go with Luke it's ridiculous but
in my heart that's the true origin story
and he's now one of the most important
characters in Star Wars in fact he is
the most important character in Star
Wars this is the way now though Mando
showed up to say the day he's not given
the war Mr welcomes and the armor very
much repeats the things that she said
during the book of Boba Fett kind of
view this as being a catcher for those
that miss that show as it's almost word
for word what was said there she sees
him as being irredeemable due to the
Living Waters no longer exist sting but
Mandos brought a rare gem with best
score and an inscription on it the armor
says and this Relic only proves that
mandalore's entire surface has been
crystallized by Fusion race now Sabine
ran revealed that when she was in the
Imperial Academy that she designed a
device which could burn baskar armor
this was called The Duchess and it
allowed a targeted laser to superheat
bescarama in order to disintegrate it
this could explain how we see best God
destroyed here and how the Imperials
actually managed to destroy the Dome on
Mandalore it's a good sign though as it
shows that Mandalore might not be lost
and this very much sets at the stake
that the mandalorians can Return to the
Planet Mana then germs through
hyperspace and they look look at the
lights mate I think grogu in this
episode very much just represents being
a kid and I remember being that agent
seeing hyperspace for the first time and
thinking that as well amongst the lights
grow who notices some pergil and these
space whales have made numerous
appearances in the Canon this mentioned
in the high Republic quest for the City
they made a big impact in Rebels which
this season will likely be taking lots
of things from as well living in deep
space they developed the natural ability
to travel at hyperdrive speed and they
were used for navigation and also
exploration grogu is blown away by them
but we see Mando catching some z's
because Lightspeed probably lost its
Allure due to how much they did at the
start of Rise of Skywalker now Mando
arrives at Navarro we're not getting
political which is absolutely thriving
now as a trade center in the Galaxy as
he walks through the streets we see an
ebony protocol Droid which were
extremely expensive and this shows the
transformation on the planet who also
catch an EV Droid but he's not torturing
he's just doing some nice stuff and
being a really great guy there's also R5
there as well and this could be how Mano
gets a Droid for his Starfighter later
on and the streets we can catch a coup
or is it cool or old Chef Droid which
appeared in Attack of the Clones and
book of Boba Fett you also see some
calamari and a little bat on someone
shoulder like a parrot not the first
pirate illusion that we get and this
could very much be foreshadowing a
stereotype that pops up later on now at
this point in the tree we see some
kawakian monkey lizards just hanging
around you probably recognize these as
being the same species as salacious B
crumb who used to be the brains behind
Jabba's organization I know he wasn't
confirmed as that but I always thought
the name salacious be crumb sounded very
upper class and that gave the game away
that he was the real one running the
show
[Music]
okay and no the this does show a major
change in the culture of the planet
though and every time we Revisited it
it's gotten better and better and better
since the first season there's been
major improvements and if you put them
side by side to compare you can see how
much the planet's grown the quaking
monkey lizards were also being roasted
in that like Luke's aunt and uncle but
here we see that they're now free to
roam now he wants more see the statue of
ig-11 who sacrificed himself at the end
of season one he pretty much represents
the heroes that have helped to reform
the planet and he's known inspiration to
those that live on it everything has
changed and as the band jams away we can
feel the atmosphere is completely
different also this is the first time I
noticed that the stones ig11 standing on
look like Stormtrooper helmets though we
gotta look at the Statue last season
this gives us a much better one and the
character now represents triumph over
the Fallen Empire at this point grief
cargo walks towards Mando and I don't it
might be a reach but I very much felt
like this was ripping on this scene from
predator
I also love how beside him you can catch
little droids carrying his cloak and we
discover that he's now the high
magistrate of the planet Mando has
encountered one before and during the
Ahsoka episode the pair faced off
against one that wasn't as friendly we
see how leaving the Empire has allowed
business in the people to flourish and
we of course know what NaVorro looked
like before this planet represents the
change that's likely happened across the
entire galaxy except for Mandalore which
we'll talk more about later on now next
we get a moment that was released online
last week I love the way that Goku just
spins away in the chair using the force
to keep himself going and he also
grabbed some Skittles all red for
royalty which is it's basically a 50
year old man living his best kid life
now Apollo creep karga offers Mando a
parcel and he seems confused that Mando
completed his job of delivering Ragu to
the Jedi but he's still with him he says
it's complicated and Pedro Pascal is
maintaining his role of being the
Galaxy's best dad now groco of course
returned to mano after making the choice
to leave the Jedi this scene actually
also offers Mando a similar choice and
grief says that though he's an apostate
amongst his people he could be one of
the Gentry on Navarro he's very much
choosing what he thinks is right though
which is of course reflected in grogu
leaving the Jedi behind I love this
scene and I'm sure some of you know if
you follow me on Twitter that we just
moved house and to go discuss mortgages
and stuff and we took the kids with us
they were pretty much just doing exactly
what grogu is whilst we are trying to
discuss the series serious business of
whether the new place would have a big
enough man cave or not and I thought
this scene hit really well everything
seems really good because the Empire are
out however we see the negatives of
their absence and the law and order that
they brought us no more some Pirates
have arrived and amongst these are a
qualish and weak way now the weak way
are a species that are often portrayed
as villains in the Star Wars Universe
though the one in Sid's bar in the bad
batch is not a bad the rest tend
to be typically they're gangsters and
Pirates Who want to gain control through
intimidation and violence which play
lays heavily into this entry they are
harassing the teacher at school and this
is the location that we saw grogu
visiting in season 2. turns out it used
to be the bar from season one I'm
guessing and we get a classic Western
standoff against grief and the gang's
leader I don't think it's any
coincidence here that the species here
were also the gangsters at the start of
the book of Boba Fett but it's showing
how grief refuses to work with them
whereas Bubba wanted to also if you are
one of these aliens and you're watching
this and uh I'm not saying these are all
bad people yeah I'm not I'm not being
racist or anything
um I just I just know it's it's
something I noticed when watching the
episode
now we also get a mention of Kara June
who they've basically poochied since
dropping Gina Carano Marshall June was
apparently recruited by Special Forces
and I'm guessing that this was what the
plot of her spin-off series was going to
center around I'm not 100 on the
production of this and whether this
script for this episode had been done
before everything happened or if this
was made after and they just added it in
if you know though drop it in the
comments but I can't quite remember how
things lined up ah I was actually
surprised that they brought her up and
yeah I guess we'll see what the internet
reaction is to it clearly they felt like
they had to acknowledge it and we also
discovered that Gideon's been sent off
to a New Republic War tribunal this is
similar to the Nuremberg trials but I'm
guessing that he'll be broken out anyway
Mando wants ig11 fixed up so that he can
beat the out of Taiko with TD for
taller than thunder we will not forget
nah and I need to try to contrast so
that he can he can navigate Mandalore
one of the big arcs he had in season one
was that he didn't trust droids but he
came to respect ig11 after all that they
went to this came in the wake of the
Clone Wars and a lot of the hate for the
droids was because of how they were used
by separatists ig11s brought back online
but he goes full Terminator mode gets
red eye lasers and brings up his old
programming to kill the asset the asset
was of course what grogu was called and
he's very much reverted back to how he
was originally now he goes wild starts
crawling across the place going back to
Arnie again another Arnie reference but
the bust of grief is used to crush his
head finally Carl Weathersby Arty you
son of a
now you headbutton and this burst could
also be a reference to another Carl
Weathers franchise Rocky yuck given a
statue even in real life but Creed never
did and I maybe I'm reaching but maybe
my man calls finally getting his bronze
statue now even though ig11 is out we
know he can be brought back online and
grief takes them to the anzelans Mando
asks if they speak haties and this is
what he also said to the Frog lady in
episode 3 of season 2. now little is
known about hanzelans as their new
addition to the franchise but they have
popped up from time to time in the New
Canon and Anne's Allen popped up in the
high Republic book light of the Jedi and
Babu freck of course stole the show and
Rise of Skywalker a Halcyon star Cruiser
was also designed by one as well and I'm
pretty sure that this is where you stay
if you go to Galaxy's Edge I don't know
as I can't afford it so if he could join
the channel as a member or something
that that would really help us out do it
also huge announce to Hector Navarro no
relation to the planet but basically
going over why they're so embedded in
the tech side of the the world and dear
them being so little they're able to get
close to the machines and use their tiny
eyes to see smaller details at a much
larger scale they're very much like
mechanics when you take your car into
the shop and though they're not pets
they're pretty cute for like for like
many fat men with mustaches anyway Mando
promises to get a part for ig-11 and
they head out into space which is when
the pirate vein returns with
reinforcements it leads to a big battle
through an asteroid belt and it reminded
me a lot of the chase in Attack of the
Clones unlike the Razer Crest the N1 is
a skilled Starfighter and with Mando at
the helm he's able to outmaneuver the
other vessels I'm not 100 on the model
of these but they do look like r41 Star
Chasers which are also a new addition to
the soccer Mando moves through the
asteroids like he's Batman striking from
the shadows and taking big hits they
also pass through what looks like a
mining operation on one of the bigger
asteroids and it's such a cool action
scene that I loved seeing in this first
entry honestly I feel like this episode
had it all with us getting really big
action scenes online and in space it
looks like it's all good but dank ferric
we come across gorion shod ship guys
your stereotypical pirate with a peg leg
and a long beard he also has a pirate
coat and yet you know what I can't wait
to see this guy pop up again in the
season the Rivalry it's it's not I say
it's a rivalry it's not a massive
rivalry but I can definitely see this
character returning for some fun moments
down the line he promises to spare Mando
if he hands over his ship and I can
actually see these guys working together
down the line Amanda gives his final
lesson to grogu for this bit and he says
never trust a pirate
now from here they traveled to calamari
which is a planet based within the
Mandalore system but they arrive at a
castle and we discover that this is
where Bo katan's been stationed out at a
far cry from the glory that royalty
should have we find this desolate except
for a soul Droid who is there to greet
them she states that there's nothing
left to join and that not having the
dark saber meant that though she had as
allies have abandoned her side there is
definitely some irony here as the people
that Manda wants to follow him don't
care he has the dark say about whereas
she says that her clan will get behind
anyone who waves it around upon a mural
on the wall we see a great battle
depicted and this represents the bloody
past that the mandalorians have all that
is left is this shell now though and
with no Gloria person to follow a group
have gone back to being just mercenaries
she's a broken woman who's gained
nothing from Battle and Views getting
Mandalore back as a lost cause Mandalore
is of course all but destroyed and even
if they were to take it back it wouldn't
have anything on it worth having the
curse of Mandalore summing up now ceases
the reality and though she gives him the
directions to Mandalore she sees it as a
waste of time she's basically looking
The Last Jedi but I can see her getting
back on the cause when she learns
Mandalore can be saved anyway that ends
the episode and I really enjoyed this
trip back lots of locations and things
going on here and yeah I thought it was
a really solid way to start the season
normally in the Mandalorian you tend to
stick to one place but this had it
jumping back and forth and it just felt
like a grandest story lots of seeds
being sewn here for what lies ahead and
yeah I'm very excited to continue this
journey next week anyway that wraps up
the episode and huge apologies to
everyone for missing the bad batch the
last couple of weeks one of our editors
had a power cut for about six hours so
we couldn't do it then then the week
after I just saw lots of stuff to get
ready for the move and also make it so
we still had content coming out and then
this week we had to move and
unfortunately I just haven't had time to
cover the show I'm gonna try and get my
together for next week and at the very
least I'll do an ending explain for the
series thank you for rocking with me and
I hope this hasn't been too
disappointing as I have been enjoying
the show I know it seems like we haven't
really taken a day off in the last five
years and that's mainly because we tend
to keep stuff going out consistently but
sometimes life just gets in the way so
huge apologies again for that and we are
in a competition right now giving away
the rocky 4K box set of three
subscribers on the 15th of March all you
have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode we pick the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so
message me if that's you on Twitter at
heavy spoilers you want some honest to
watch that make sure you check out our
Brighton of The Last of Us which will be
linked on screen right now lots of stuff
to talk about in the new entry uh
there's lots of things coming as well so
if you love The Games definitely head
over there right after this by the way
thanks for sending you the video I've
been poor and May the force be with you